speaking of jobs actually like do you do
you have a day job I do have a day job
what was your hustle I work as a nanny
okay right now I'm nanny for boy girl
twins it's very exhausting yeah they're
they're almost 2 I've been with them
since they were two months old so yeah I
try the longest job I've had in a minute
I used to be I used to call myself the
part-time hero because I just worked six
part-time jobs every day until I died
yeah I just you know for someone who has
as many skills as I have you would think
I would have found like a career but I
just really never did I haven't found
like a job job that I've ever stuck with
I've just done a lot of different things
that I've been pretty good at but
nothing that's ever been like I should
do this oh yeah I mean I jumped around
yeah but all would the pursuit of comedy
in the back right I always knew I wanted
to write in some shape or form it took
me a while to figure out like how I
wanted to do it but once I did I decided
like okay well let's focus on a job that
gives me flexibility and oddly enough
being a nanny really is like the best
job for comedian for the hours yeah it's
steady
and they usually sleep part of the day
if you pick the right ages to nanny more
they'll be in school so you're working
part-time and usually you're done by
5:00 or 6:00 so it's like enough time to
get to shows I mean yet sex I usually
have to be at work at like 7:30 in the
morning it's kind of hard but yeah I've
done that but also it keeps you for
spending your whole night drinking and
being an idiot it makes you go do your
set go home go to bed attack the day
healthy the next day because you're in
charge of life you're in charge of lives
you're in charge the future of the world
yeah yeah definitely
so yeah it's been it's been a good gig I
definitely can kind of see like the
horizon of where I'm gonna hit like
critical mass and it's like time to sort
of piss or get off the pot when it comes
to comedy or like I'll have done as much
as I can do with the time I have while
working full time because right now
between like my job and like all the
things I do producing and writing and
teaching them all that like I'm
definitely working like 80 hours a week
like it's a lot that's really you know
yeah and I don't think I can do my best
at all of those things at the same time
anymore so I am kind of like a
crossroads where I'm having to
side what am I gonna do what's your
what's your plan I don't really know I
think I definitely like wanna I'm trying
to like stick it out to stay working
with my family until the kids go into
like daycare at pre-k cuz really isn't
too far down the road but if I can't I
don't know I don't know cuz I'd like to
do is I'd like to focus more on
producing I really like running shows
every like organizing shows I think I'm
getting pretty good at it I'd like to do
don't tell every week if I can but that
but don't tell that's like a lot of work
because I watch what I have to scout
venues I have to set up those
relationships I've to go check them to
make sure they are good I have to book
comics not to show up I have to set up I
mean I've got 40 folding chairs and a PA
system in my house good at all you it's
on me baby I got volunteers I get people
who like volunteer and then I let them
bring a couple of friends to the show
for free but yeah more often than not
it's just me and hopefully a very
friendly person at the venue who's
willing to help me load in some chairs
mm-hmm but I actually been really
surprised by how many people will
volunteer for don't tell we got a lot of
audience numbers who just think it's
super cool and they want to like come
back for free so they come and like work
the door or something obviously yeah I'd
love to do more don't tell it's just you
know it takes a lot of time and energy
and then the stuff I'm doing with Wendy
peach like right now I'm producing like
the open mic and a Monday night show but
I've gotten some opportunities to do
other shows other places but I just
don't know when I'd physically have the
time to go do that with what I'm doing
right now so I would love to be able to
like leave my job on like a happy now
get them I replaced my Manny and like
you know fly off on an umbrella like
Mary Poppins comeback and Mary Poppins
too when they're adults and then be able
to focus on just trying to do what I'm
doing now but like a little bit more
because I also have like other like tiny
little irons in the fire like there's a
great website called comedy wire yeah
there's like a sort of setup like Reddit
and there's like a part that's free we
can just like write headline jokes and
you know fun stuff and eventually like
if you get up voted and people like like
your material on there they might invite
you to the pro side which is mostly just
like a bunch of freelance gigs for like
radio and podcast commercials for like
jewelers it's like not very exciting or
money but every so often there's like a
cool go down there like I've gotten to
write tweets for like Wendy's and I've
gotten to oh you know write copy for
like big festivals like stuff like that
this is all paid work yeah and it's you
know there's different bids not a lot
but if you know you write a couple ads a
day and you win the bid because you post
your bid and your like competing with
other people for the bid and then the
client will pick their favorite and then
you'll either split the pot if multiple
ones get picked or you get to take the
whole pot Oh usually between like 10 and
30 bucks but sometimes they're more
sometimes they're like a couple hundred
and they do like contests and giveaways
the base gave away like a free year of
that master class you know that like
online class like Judd Apatow Steve
Martin stuff they had like a con right
in contests like right a Steve Martin s
quip and then they picked their favorite
one in that person won a year of master
closet this is comedy wire yeah so like
this is like a lot of little stuff you
can get out of it but yeah I would love
to like focus on doing more of that
during the day and you know submitting
articles to people because I would love
to like write again that's not comedy
necessarily yeah you're I'd love to
audition I have you know i've got a
voice-over demo but i've never done an
audition in atlanta you know what i mean
like and it's just cuz i haven't had the
time i've never even like pursued
getting like management are getting
representation which i think is
something I'm starting to need to move
on to the next thing I want to do but to
do that I'm gonna have to free up about
40 hours a week I can see where I might
be able to make more income and sustain
myself but it's also just like such a
huge risk and that's very nerve-racking
for me when I when I decided to go
full-time I made a list of like all the
pros and cons of like okay if I go
full-time
what are all the awesome things that
could happen what's the worst-case
scenario what could happen and the pros
far outweighed the cons
I was just like were you were you
married at that point like you were I
was not saying I was living in a studio
apartment in on Boulevard I was like the
frontlines of gentrification but and I
was I was a hotel minibar attendant so
like I worked my way I like was at
enterprise and then I gradually from
there took jobs that paid less but gave
me more time and I kind of weaned myself
into comedy full-time that way and I had
a I saved up $10,000 yeah and that's
just what I jumped into comedy with I
was like okay I have $10,000 let me that
was like goal one save that and then I
did all my pros and cons and was like
well it seems like yeah which is weird
right it is it's like this is what I was
born to do wait should I dunno it's
finally here but it is like when you
when you step into that world then the
world will start to reveal itself to you
and his opportunities will start to yeah
you got to kind of like take the leave
you know yeah you can't be available if
you're not there you know it's like what
I keep telling myself cuz yeah I think
for me like my plan I see all these like
little things I can do to sustain myself
I have the time I have some
opportunities with some clubs that like
nationally that like me maybe could book
a more Road work I could start doing
next I really haven't done much of that
yeah and I could you know pick up a
part-time job I could do little things
here and there like there's always ways
to make little amounts of money you know
I just have to like remind myself like
it can be done
I breath